let's see who is joining us today from
the 203 area code caller from 203 what's
your name where are you calling from
hey this is Shiv I'm calling from Boston
hey Shiva what's going on well I wonder
I saw your appearance on Joe Rogan and I
was actually curious if you were
familiar with them Chomsky's propaganda
model yes I am so I guess I just wanted
you pointed out to Joe
I guess that these companies that kind
of have a public image of kind of being
liberal institutions so I doesn't want
to get kind of generally comments on how
right now I guess this right wing kind
of I guess these day of Ruben type 10
cool types are kind of criticizing
Twitter or YouTube for being leftist
organizations one in actuality I suppose
that's the image that they're trying to
put out so in a lot of ways these are
actually hard right-wing capitalist
organizations that are trying to make
people think that they're liberal to
kind of get away with pushing that
right-wing agenda and I think I kind of
want to get your thoughts on that you
brought that up with Joe Rogan yeah
that's really good and I'm glad to have
a chance to talk about this more because
so for people who don't know what what
Shiv is talking about very briefly on
the Joe Rogan program Joe said Google
YouTube clearly is left-wing and I said
in what way and he said well you know
it's like they're based in Silicon
Valley and like everybody there is
liberal and and I think he said maybe
like their their CEO is liberal or
something like that and I made the case
I wasn't saying there is no way in which
you could qualify YouTube as as
left-leaning and I'll say more about
that in a second but what I pointed out
is YouTube is a huge corporation their
primary interest and their motivations
and most of the decisions they make are
financial and they benefit financially
from pushing sort of right-wing
supply-side low-tax anti-regulation
stuff and that that's not super
left-wing now I do think the one thing I
didn't say Shiv and I think is a fair
criticism is that there's a difference
between saying YouTube's structurally
and economically is right-wing vs.
YouTube's internal culture is right-wing
you can have a situation where YouTube's
internal work culture
or Facebook's internal work culture is
more progressive hipstery left-leaning
whatever and yet still their outward
facing sort of structural economic
priorities line up more with low tax
anti-regulation right-wingers and i
didn't get a chance to say that on rogen
and i think that that is an important
missing piece so while i completely
agree with you like yes the the
corporatist priorities of these
companies are are sort of more in line
with republicans any company is looking
to make money looking to make money is
not necessarily left-wing or right-wing
and the culture can still be one that is
a left-wing culture we just have to
parse through it and have more of a
detailed nuanced conversation yeah it's
a good point I think what kind of irks
me about I guess this critique of social
media coming from I guess these
so-called free speech advocates is that
they're kind of conflating the idea of
social liberal ideology with having gay
pride with economic ideology so the
other thing that's missing from that
which i think is interesting is
increasingly just recognizing diversity
or having anti you know anti bullying
and harassment on the lines of
homophobic slurs or whatever
increasingly that's just called being a
good normal person who exists in society
yeah I think it's unfair now to like
what are you saying about the right when
you say if there is an anti homophobia
policy that's a left-wing company like
are you saying that the right is Pro
homophobia at a certain point we just
have to recognize this is just behaving
like good people
yeah no definitely people are definitely
strong Manning each other in that sense
all right schiff thank you very much
appreciate the phone call thank you okay
take care